hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
there is a really fascinating and I
think also very useful discussion a
topic that epictetus is calling on a
melodious and we're translating as
inconsistency not being the same not
that remaining the same over time and
its relation to our moral failings in
chapter 21 of a book to now why is this
so interesting partly because of where
it's going to go then you'll see that at
the very end of this but partly because
epictetus is examining something that
it's not about so basic principles
so much as how the process of philosophy
as therapy of the self actually proceeds
and some of the resistances that you are
likely to encounter not only you know in
your own self but looking at everybody
else and seeing how human nature tends
to play itself out when it's not
completely developed or clarified so he
says you know why do people admit to
certain faults quite readily and then
not want to admit to other faults this
is a fascinating question why are people
willing to some people are now in admit
any faults right we know that but those
are pretty rare some people are willing
to say yeah I'm bad in this respect but
I'm not going to say that I'm bad in
this respect and he gives some examples
of this he says nobody wants to admit
that they're foolish or unintelligent
although in some other passages he does
have somebody saying yeah I'm a fool but
in general quite the contrary here
everyone says I wish I had as much luck
as I have sense they readily admit that
they're timid and they say I'm a bit
timid
but in general you will not find me to
be a fool a person will not readily
admit that their their lack of
self-control not at all but they're
unjust and will never admit that they're
envious or meddlesome but most men will
admit that they are moved by pity what
is the reason for this why are they
willing to talk to some negative traits
and they're totally unwilling to even
entertain the possibility that it might
be the case that they are unjust or you
know wrap through with envy or those
sorts of things so that doesn't genuine
question what's the answer to it
well part of it is what he calls
confusion or tinaka about the good and
the bad disturbance about the good a
sort of disorder in our viewpoints on
things so how did that fit in there well
the part of it is is what what's really
good or bad right people are confused
about what is genuinely good for human
beings and what is bad for them and so
you know if they think that something is
bad even though it's not they don't want
to see themselves and somehow being
blemished by that if they think that
something is good they want to protect
that within themselves and they want to
deny what would go against that here's
an interesting part of them is admitting
that there's something wrong with you it
could
thing or a bad thing now that's a
question that doesn't have a simple
answer right because it kind of depends
on what you're admitted so it goes back
to this question why are we willing to
admit some things and not to admit other
things about ourselves now you know
think about how much what is you know
consider to be good or bad has changed
over time
right there are certain things that in
our culture today which is different
than say Victorian culture or different
than say the you know cultures of the
Middle Ages that we readily admit we
have no problem with whatsoever but
would be a total scandal back at man
time there's other things by the way
that we find totally scandalous that
they thought were okay for the culture
that they were in why here's another
apartment not only are people confused
about what really is good or bad they're
also confused about how to order things
what really is better or what is worse
you know is is it a worse thing to be
seated at a dinner party and to
accidentally belch save you the pause of
the conversations that everybody hears
it
most of us would be mortified if that
sort of thing happened to us right and
even the person next to us we might be
like yeah though that wasn't me that was
that guy over there right cuz we don't
know what else to think that about it
but think about some other things that
people might be doing at dinner parties
that are far worse seducing somebody
else's spouse shouldn't that be a
shameful thing and yet people will turn
a blind eye to that sort of thing and
they'll concentrate on the person who
disrupts etiquette there's all sorts of
things along these lines where people
get mixed up about what's worse and
what's better so every team is to sort
of you know points that he makes about
this to tell us how people what's the
logic by which people actually work out
these sort of
decisions well one thing is they don't
want to admit to what appears to them to
be shameful not even notice he doesn't
say is really shameful he says quite
frankly in their using the word
fantastic fantastic I you know the peers
to them to be shameful that's what what
they imagine what they think right
what they assess and it might involve
what other people do as well because our
assumptions about this take into account
our culture and other people but we
could be quite wrong about you know we
sometimes to have the experience of
being liberated from worrying about
something that it turns out nobody cares
about whatsoever you know for example do
I need to wear a tie or not for these
videos is there some sort of rule that
says for doing an academic video you
must be wearing a tie and at least a
sweater or a jacket no nobody cares
about that sort of stuff I I do it in
part because you know for me it's just
part of the practice of being an
academic sometimes wear a tie sometimes
and don'ts you know it's not something
that really fits into all of this if I
thought that that was absolutely
essential to doing this sort of task I
might feel relieved to find out that
it's not and so you know things that
appear to the to us to be shameful those
are the things we don't want to admit so
you know think for example about how
radically the culture has changed from
generation to generation you know there
are people who brag about things that
just a generation ago you would try to
keep under wraps there's you know we
have all sorts of examples but the way
that was happening in ancient Rome as
well there was this culture clash
occurring another thing is people will
admit to what seems to be involuntary or
he has some sort of involuntary aspect
to it
so Epictetus gives some examples of his
own time that i think still apply to our
oh she says here we go if a person does
grudgingly admit that they are a crack
that they don't have laughs you know
self-control or something like that they
will say that they're in love because
that people will excuse that or that
there's something else going on with
them because then it seems like an
involuntary act right people who get mad
and lose their temper they blame it on
the other person they say I was forced I
was in a situation where I couldn't help
doing that sort of thing you know the
reason why people are inclined to admit
timidity or pity or things like that is
because we feel that those sorts of
emotions or reactions are not things
that we really have control over and you
know if you think that you don't have
control over any of the emotions well
then the emotions are things that you're
willing to put out there and say that's
just the way it is for me if of course
you're stoic or any other people with a
that who say that we have some control
over our emotions and we have some
responsibility for it that might not be
so inclined to admit to your you know
bad emotional reactions he goes on and
he says injustice people don't conceive
of it as involuntary so they don't want
to admit it if they do something that's
wrong they will usually say well
mistakes were made
now I actually chose to do something
that I knew was wrong at the time I
committed injustice because they see
that as something that is within the
realm of a person's choice jealousy he
says in jealousy there's an element of
the involuntary so this is a fault that
men will grudgingly admit another thing
that goes along with this that Epictetus
doesn't bring up here but is really
applicable to our own time people may
reframe the narratives that they tell
about themselves and other people and
how they
so that faults become involuntary and
that they can admit them you could
actually see you know the processes of
certain forms of psychotherapy has
geared towards towards helping people to
see that things are not really all
entirely their fault
when the therapy is working well or that
it's other people's fault or society's
fault or pick whatever else you like or
I have a condition when it's something
else people are willing to come to you
if they have some diagnosed condition
and tell you all about it because we no
longer see for the most part in our
society medical conditions is shameful
now we actually see them as something
that we have to show sympathy for and
make exceptions for so a person is
willing to admit that because it seems
to them to be something totally out of
their control it's involuntary from a
stoic perspective certain physical
conditions probably pretty involuntary
unless the way that you're living has
choices that you've made about your
lifestyle has lended them so for example
if you're a smoker and you have
emphysema the stoic is not going to say
yes that's totally involuntary because
you have some sort of role in what led
to them but the option is there's many
things that people will you know open up
to and admit provided they can turn them
into being something involuntary I don't
have a moral failure with respect to
drinking I'm an alcoholic it's just a
disease well that's a big open question
isn't I have the genetic predisposition
to that sort of thing you know stoicism
is really focused on having us analyze
why we behave the way we do how its
oriented towards what we think is good
and bad whether we have our conceptions
of good and bad you know well worked out
so that they they make sense across the
board or whether they're still in
consistent now notice what Epictetus
says that has this very very interesting
to close-up it says when sucker the men
we live over so confused so ignorant
both of what they mean by evil What evil
quality the ham or whether they had one
or if so how they came to have it or how
they will get rid of it among such men I
wonder whether it is not worthwhile for
us also to watch ourselves each of one
asking himself the questions is it
possible that I too in one of those
people
what conceit that my cherishing
regarding myself how do I have ducked
myself do I have for my part act like a
wise man do I act like a man of
self-control do I ever say that I've
been educated that to me whatever comes
am i the consciousness proper to a
person who knows nothing that I do not
know anything he keeps on going on and
on with us are we living what we're
preaching as if we had wanna be Stoics
or are we just you know thinking this
sort of stuff out and they're not
applying that's a very good question all
of this stuff right here why do people
admit to some things being wrong about
themselves but not to others that
applies to us equally and that could
apply to why we're so willing to
diagnose why other people have all this
screwed up mentality and use that as a
way to not focus about ourselves for
stoicism there is going to be this this
intrinsic focus on self scrutiny and
making sure that these things apply
equally to ourselves when we see other
people doing this we ought to say are we
reflecting that ourselves is that
something that applies to us are we
getting to the root of what's really
wrong with us are we willing to admit
the stuff that truly is voluntary and
saying oh we have screwed it up a lot in
the past so that then we can diagnose it
and figure out how we can undo the day
we've done and start to make progress
towards the good that is something that
is a real upshot of looking at
inconsistency in other people we can see
it in ourselves as well